and we do thank you for staying with us
here at 6 30. I'm Denise Valdez I'm
Brian Loftus after days in meetings
Nevada lawmakers have passed a bill to
help fund a baseball stadium for the A's
right here in Las Vegas 8 news now
reporter Brian will joining us now with
the latest details in fact we've had
this as breaking news at five o'clock
right yeah Brian Denise good evening
lawmakers decided yes to provide up to
380 million dollars in public financing
to help build a 1.5 billion dollar 30
000 seat Stadium on the Las Vegas Strip
now the bill heads to the governor's
desk for his signature the big question
that remains is will the two amendments
added to the bill put it in Jeopardy
when the governor looks at it while the
governor's office would not comment this
morning the amendment contains two bills
that the governor previously vetoed one
of those removes an exception to pay
prevailing wages and monorail projects
while the other requires companies to
provide 12 weeks of paid family leave if
they receive government money the
monorail portion could apply to the
extension of the Tesla Loop plan for the
state Stadium the bill passed the
assembly today before heading back to
the senate for a final vote
and all those in favor signify by saying
aye nay
and the eyes have it the motion is
carried
Senate bill number one
with this amendment number two uh has
been has been um
has been passed and enrolled ordered
enrolled and there's somebody to be
notified of our action
that was the Senate passage and earlier
the assembly passed the a stadium bill
by a vote of 25 to 15 with two
abstaining one slight change was made
which UPS the minimum per year from the
A's towards scholarships and mentorships
to about two million dollars this is
after five days of this special session
we now wait for the governor to sign the
bill if that happens the stadium could
be open for the 2028 baseball season in
the studio Brian will eight news now